my favorite sh is watching Rand on
Twitter say how dumb he is I'm like I'm
like bro first of all like we were
talking earlier about doctors who have
like it's like you're stay in your lane
it's like okay Elon stay in your lane
Advanced
rocketry business success electric car
electric car engineering just stay in
those Lanes buddy don't talk about Free
Speech
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay Hey Joe
what did Elon tell Bob Iger to do we got
no he said peace love unity respect
Disney I love you that's what he said
the four elements of hip-hop yeah no he
said [__] off like straight up just two
words he said go [__] yourself that's
right why did he say that Joe because
they're trying to extort me with money
are you serious you if you don't want to
advertise on my platform then [__] off
[__] [__] yourself and so most
corporations said okay and then they
started I will [__] myself and not only
that we'll [__] each other yeah does and
does is Elon still doubling down he he
appears to be still doubling down yes so
Disney pulled their ad a lot of them
pulled a lot of them all at once so not
just Disney but probably everybody
that's like a lot of the corporate like
interests have pulled ads from from X
but did you hear how Disney plus dropped
like a [__] yes so that's the
war now it there's a war on now between
Elon Who says let's let planet Earth
deci side which is a wild quote let's
let Planet wait what do you mean in
response to what so this is why I think
it's genius for the longest time for
like the last like half decade it felt
like all the social media was like ran
by like the super left right and then so
it's so much so where anyone that wants
to hear anything that's on the right
they got to like make their own [__]
[__] parlor whatever all those other
social truth social Rumble all those
things
so now um Elon I personally believe he
is just trying to make free speech I
don't think he's like right or left I
feel like he's just like let's just get
it back to where it's just like everyone
can be accepted over here and I think
that's threatening to the super left
people so I feel like um when he says
well [__] off and if all these left
companies all pull out then just like
how um Dana White signed Bud Light back
into the UFC I feel like all now it's
time for all these right companies to
come in and then buy the ad space yeah
and then now the that's like almost the
worst nightmare for the left because now
the major platforms are now right
leaning you know so now X which used to
be or Twitter used to be left leaning
was like elon's like I'm going to give
you guys a chance to be balanced but if
you don't want to then I'm just going to
give it to like this side and I feel
like it's like it's
it's like almost like the Super Genius
like move for him to say [__] you cuz
he's just like re like scrambling the
whole an Farm what do you think his his
end game is you think he's just too rich
to care I think he really just wants
free speech and he's just like is down
to just play ball until he goes bankrupt
I I was thinking about this too like so
usually when people make moves there's a
end game to what they think that yeah
and then I'm like well this dude's got
okay like you think it's all about money
but he's already got money like he
doesn't give a [__] about money he's
like top 10 richest men in the world
right isn't he number one uh he's top
three or like but he's but but at that
point you can't even spend at all
million you can't it's it's impossible
so I think at that point wouldn't you do
things that are just more like all right
um this is what I feel is right so I'm
going to do it [__] you money yeah
that's literal [__] you money cuz he's
and I think it's hard for people to it's
hard for people to think in the way that
he thinks because or put themselves in
his shoes cuz he's the guy that sold
PayPal and took the whole thing and go
Tesla SpaceX whatever hey can I borrow
some money to live in your apartment so
he literally does not give a [__] about
money so like because of that like he
can make crazy moves that people are
like what the [__] why would anyone do
that it's like cuz he's thinking on
another level my favorite [__] is
watching Rand on Twitter say how dumb he
is I'm like I'm like bro first of all
like we were talking earlier about
doctors who have like it's like you're
stay in your lane it's like okay Elon
stay in your lane Advanced rocketry
[__] business success electric car
electric car engineering just stay in
those Lanes buddy don't talk about Free
Speech
okay people constantly throw stones at
that dude I'm like dude you could call
him a lot of things but dumb I don't
think is one but then the funniest thing
is people will listen to that and go
well he didn't do it he paid other
people that figure it out they did it
I'm like dude he literally knows how the
rocket works that's not the same thing
you think Jeff Bezos knows how the
rocket
works for me I'm like so people will
take this as like Elon Brown NOS in
right it's like whatever for me I'm like
I'm just glad that a a billionaire
actually did something that they cared
about for for what people have been
asking for which is like people go man
if you're so [__] rich why don't you
put your money where your mouth is and
and do what you say they actually
tweeted at him remember and then he
bought the because of that he go well
you know what I I will buy Twitter
that's literally what he's doing what I
like about the whole thing here is that
there are a lot of us who feel that
being on YouTube Instagram Facebook
during lockdown during you know the
cancel culture [__] like all of that it
affected all of us especially in the
comedy space and everyone was like well
I don't want to lose my sponsorship cuz
I ain't like eting Rich you know but
also we just didn't want to be [__]
burned at the stake without a trial so
everyone was self-editing everyone was
like oh should we make this joke should
we not make this joke and then what he
did with Twitter is he created a space
where people can actually talk and I'm
only talking about things that I I just
want to like explore ideas I'm not even
talking about hey let's let let's let
the white supremacist come in and be
free like I'm not even saying that you
do say that sometimes though yeah I
heard you say it once maybe maybe but
I'm not even saying the extreme [__] I'm
saying you know I just want to play with
ideas cuz remember if you questioned
anything about Co if you questioned
anything about media if you said
anything away from like whatever the the
Hollywood narrative was all of a sudden
you're some crazy guy or people hate you
or whatever and I'm like why why can't
we just like have conversations about
ideas dude ior Mech in equals horse Bas
was the craziest one that was craziest
one by far what did he say or do I just
said I just said what everyone said what
what did he say no no not he he didn't
say it but like people Joe Rogan was
talking about Ivor mechon as a possible
covid remedy and then everyone was like
he's telling everyone to take horse
paste and it's like oh what yeah I
didn't know that yeah and then they
[__] showed they reposted his video
but with a green filter he looked yeah
they made him look ugly yeah they made
him look all old dumb ass Joe Rogan got
Co of did cuz he's taking horse manure
paste and [__] and then they took his
video and and why would they do this
unless they have an agenda they they put
a green filter on top of it to make him
look sickly yeah yeah when the real
video he just looks completely normal
and he's fine he's saying he's fine and
that it worked and he's healthy and
thank you he's got beat it in two days
this is what I used check it out you
know what's crazy to me is um so like
living in Hawaii it's a very Democratic
state right but I remember the Democrats
were like representative of Working
Class People in manufacturing and and
unions and things like that police they
were police friendly they were like
firemen friendly the police and fire
unions loved the Democrat yeah because
that's what they were and and Hawaii
it's still kind of like that right but I
think this whole what happened during
lockdown and this whole takeover of like
Silicon Valley San Francisco leftist
which is like super super left and then
they're working alongside media and cuz
it's it's just California leftism right
cuz if you go talk to a democrat in like
Georgia they're not the same same with
like you know I'm sure if you go
Minnesota and talk to a Democrat they're
not the crazy left left San Francisco
aarian corporatists yeah they're like
Silicon Valley and they're talking about
like minority rights as if they're not
billionaires you know I'm like shut the
[__] up that is kind of funny actually
right and then they're living in these
gated communities
in in in all white neighborhoods talking
about we need to like do these things
for folks and it's like you don't even
live amongst Black Folk talking about
and then when remember when Rhonda santz
sent those those migrants to to where
the [__] was it Martha's Vineyard the
Liberals like got put them all on a bus
and then like held up like peace and
love signs as they're leaving that was
the best [__] and they went we simply do
not have the resources to take them
obviously but what's what's crazy to me
is that a lot of Democrats are actually
leaving the Democratic party cuz it's
getting so crazy right like like there's
RFK you know he's been a Democrat
forever and now he's running as
independent there's Tulsi gabard she
left Andrew Yang he created his own
forward party and I think the the idea
of what is left is gone so [__] far
to the left that everyone's like what
the [__] I'm not right but the right's
the only place that's kind of allowing
this conversation to happen well dude I
mean and in 2003 when Bush was getting
us into Iraq the Democrats were voting
for it yeah and then they were the only
people [__] on it afterward but like
while they're clearing all the bills
voting for it so this is where I get
back to my refrain which is like it's
just a big corporatist party and they
just live action role playay like they
care about certain things but when it
comes to the main topics of like war and
sending money to other countries for God
knows whatever reason while letting um
cities here burn and languish they're
all together that's why when I'm always
talking about um politics here it's like
I have to also preface it by like I
don't actually think that the right or
the left is the benevolent party right
like there's within the party they're
owned by the same sponsors Ron [__]
Lockheed Martin like all of them that
are representing those companies they're
working for the same side whether you're
yeah just look at the policies and which
politician votes for let's give more
money to Ukraine then you'll know where
their allegiances are and then right now
though I think what's pretty awesome and
Elon Joe Rogan a lot of these guys are a
part of this even within the Republican
side you see like new candidates like
Vivic or whatever but they're having
conversations that we've been wanting to
talk about not like all the same
[__] that like media has been saying
is like we need to spread democracy and
other these poor countries and we need
to come and bomb the [__] out of it so
they could be democracies like I mean
that's crazy peoplein has weap mass
destruction yeah all that [__] yeah but
what I like about it now is that you can
have a real conversation they're not
lying to your face and if they try they
get smashed down from people that are
actually like shut the [__] up dude
we're having a Real Talk there's a place
to talk about it now cuz and I talk
about this all the time I don't care
I'll talk about it again Scott Ritter in
200 and the buildup to the Iraq War he
was the un weapons inspector and he was
like hi everybody I'm the head of the UN
weapons inspector program Saddam doesn't
have weapons mass destruction and they
treated him like they put a clown nose
on his face basically every time that he
went on one of these shows that had four
people just talk talk bombing him into
Oblivion calling him a crackpot and [__]
it's like he's literally the [__]
head of the program he's trying to tell
everybody they don't have it and then of
course we found out he was dead right
like years later yeah and that's but
that's what they do if you talk out
against it you're a crackpot Ron Paul
was a crackpot when he was talking [__]
about how Bush basically creates more
terrorism by bombing the [__] out of the
Middle East and every one of the
Republicans on the stage Turk turns
laughing at him and and pointing at him
and calling him a crackpot but I thought
what's crazy now is that you see Vivic
he's free to speak right and he'll go to
Nikki Haley call her a [__] straight
up Warhawk D Chris christe like we've
been following this for such a long time
that I feel like it's finally like oh
what a relief what a relief that there's
this this is even being opened where
before people would be like sh that's
not even something you can talk about
yeah and I like I like all of them I
like Vivic I like RFK I like anybody
who's going to just give somebody the
bird yeah cuz that's my attitude about
the whole thing me too and like Nancy
Pelosi Nancy Pelosi's got big tits big
old
[Music]
titties